so we have f of X is equal to 3x squared
minus 18x minus 81 over 6x squared minus
54 now what I want to do in this video
is find the equations for the horizontal
and vertical asymptotes and I encourage
you to pause the video right now and try
to work it out on your own before I try
to work through it so I'm assuming
you've had a go at it so let's think
about each of them so let's first think
about the horizontal or is antal
asymptote horizontal asymptotes see if
there at least is one so the horizontal
asymptote is really what is the line the
horizontal line that f of X approaches
as the absolute value of X approaches as
the absolute value of X approaches
infinity or you could say what does f of
X approach as X approaches infinity and
what does X f of X approach as X
approaches negative infinity so there's
a couple of ways you could think about
it let me just rewrite the definition of
f of X right over here so it's 3x
squared minus 18x minus 81 all of that
over 6x squared minus 54 now there's
there's two ways you can think about it
one you could say okay as X as the
absolute value of x becomes larger and
larger and larger the highest degree
terms in the numerator and the
denominator going to dominate are going
to Dum the numerator the denominator are
going to are going to dominate and so
what are the highest degree terms well
in the numerator you have 3x squared and
in the denominator you have 6x squared
so as X approaches so as the absolute
value of x approaches infinity these two
terms are going to dominate f of X is
going to become approximately 3x squared
over 6 x squared these other terms are
going to matter less obviously minus 54
is I'm going to grow at all and minus
18x is going to grow much slower than
the
the x-squared the highest degree terms
are going to are going to be what
dominates and if we look at just those
terms then you could think of
simplifying it in this way so that's
going f of X is going to get closer and
closer to 3 6 or 1/2 so you could say
that there's a horizontal asymptote at y
is equal to Y is equal to 1/2 another
way we could have thought about this if
you don't like this whole little bit of
hand wavy argument that these two terms
dominate is that we can divide the
numerator and the denominator by the
highest degree or X raised to the
highest power in the numerator and the
denominator so the highest degree term
is x squared in the numerator so let's
do so let's divide the numerator and the
denominator or I guess you could say the
highest degree term in the numerator and
the denominator is x squared so let's
divide both the numerator and
denominator by that so if you multiply
the numerator times 1 over x squared and
the denominator times 1 over x squared
notice we're not changing the value of
of the entire expression we're just
multiplying it times 1 if we assume X
does not equal 0 and so we get 2 so in
our numerator let's see 3 x squared
divided by x squared is going to be 3
minus 18 over X minus 81 over x squared
and then all of that over 6 x squared
times 1 over x squared that's just going
to be 6 and then minus 54 over x squared
so what's going to happen what's the if
you want to think in terms of if you
want to think of limits as something
approaches infinity so if you want to
say the limit as X approaches infinity
here what's going to happen well this
this and that are going to approach 0 so
you're going to approach 3/6 or 1/2 now
if you said as X approaches negative
infinity it would be the same thing this
this and this approach 0 and once again
you approach 1/2 so that's the
horizontal asymptote Y is equal to 1/2
now let's think about the vertical
asymptotes
so let me write that down right over
here let me scroll over a little bit so
vertical vertical asymptotes or possibly
asymptotes vertical maybe there is more
than one now it might be very tempting
to say okay you hit a vertical asymptote
whenever the denominator equals zero
which would make this rational
expression undefined and as we'll see
for this case that is not that is not
exactly right
just making the denominator equal to
zero by itself will not make a vertical
asymptote it will definitely be a place
where the function is undefined but by
itself it does not make a vertical
asymptote so let's just think about this
denominator right over here so we can
factor it out actually let's factor out
the numerator and the denominator so we
can rewrite this as f of X is equal to
the numerator is clearly every term is
divisible by three so let's factor out
of three it's going to be three times x
squared minus 6x minus 27 all of that
over the denominator each term is
divisible by six six times x squared
minus nine and let's see we can we can
factor the numerators and denominators
denominators out further so this is
going to be f of X is equal to three
times let's see two numbers their
product is negative twenty seven their
sum is negative six negative nine and
three seemed to work so you can have X
minus nine times X plus three just
factor the numerator over the
denominator this is the difference of
squares right over here so this would be
X minus three times X plus three so when
does the denominator equal when does the
denominator equal zero so the
denominator denominator equals zero when
X is equal to positive three or X is
equal to negative 3 now I encourage your
pause this video for a second think
about are both of these vertical
asymptotes
well you might realize that the
numerator also equals zero
when X is equal to negative three so
what we can do is actually simplify this
a little bit and then it becomes a
little bit clearer where our vertical
asymptotes are so we could say that f of
X we could we could essentially divide
the numerator and denominator by X plus
3 and we just have to key if we want the
function to be identical we have to keep
the caveat that the function itself is
not defined when X is equal to negative
3 that definitely did make us divide by
0 so we have to remember that but that
will simplify the expression so this
exact same function is going to be if we
divide the numerator and denominator by
X plus 3 it's going to be 3 times X
minus 9 over 6 times X minus 3 for X
does not equal 4 X does not equal
negative 3 notice this is an identical
definition to our original function and
I have to I have to put this qualifier
right over here for X does not equal
negative 3 because our original function
is undefined at x equals negative 3 x
equals negative 3 is not a part of the
domain of our original function and so
we if we take it out like if we take X
plus 3 out of the numerator and
denominator we have to remember that if
we just put this right over here this
wouldn't be the same function because
this without the qualifier is defined
for x equals negative 3 but we want to
have the exact same function so you
would actually have a point
discontinuity right over here and now we
could think about the vertical
asymptotes now the vertical asymptotes
going to be a point that makes the
denominator equals 0 but not the
numerator equal to 0 x equals negative 3
made both equal 0 so our vertical
asymptotes I'll do this in green just to
just a switch or blue our vertical
vertical asymptote asymptote is going to
be at X is equal to X is equal to
positive 3 that's what made the
denominator equal zero but not the
numerator so let me write that the
vertical asymptote is X is equal to 3
and so using these two points of
of information or I guess what we just
figured out you can start to attempt to
sketch sketch the graph this by itself
is not going to be enough you might want
to also plot a few points to see what
happens of I guess around the asymptotes
as we approach as we approach the two
different asymptotes but if we were to
look at if we were to look at a graph
actually let's just do it
let's just do it for let's just do it
for fun here just to complete the
picture for ourselves the function is
going to look something like this it's
going to look something like this and
I'm not doing it at scale so if that's 1
and this is 1/2 right over here y equals
1/2 is the horizontal asymptote y equals
1/2 is a horizontal asymptote Y is equal
to 1/2 and we have a vertical asymptote
at X is equal to positive 3 so we have
1/2 Ln 2 then in blue 1 2 3 once again I
didn't draw it to scale or the x and y's
aren't on the same scale but we have a
vertical asymptote just like that but
just looking at this we don't know
exactly what the function looks like it
could look like something like this it
could it and maybe does something like
that or it could do something like that
or it could do it could do something
like that and that or something like
that and that so hopefully you get the
idea here and to figure out what it does
you would actually want to try out some
points and the other thing we want to be
clear is that the function is also not
defined at X is equal to at x is equal
to negative 3 so if this is so let me
make x equals negative 3 here so x
equals negative 3 so 1 2 3 so the
function might look and once again I
haven't tried out the points it could
look something like this it could look
something where we're not a whoops where
we're not defined at negative 3 we're
not defined at negative 3 and then it
goes something like this
and maybe just something like that or
maybe it does maybe it does something
like maybe does something like that it's
not defined at negative 3 this will be
some toad right now so to get closer and
closer and it can go something like that
or it goes something like that and once
again to decide which of these it is you
would actually want to try out a few
values so I encourage you to - after
this video try that out in yourself and
try to figure out what the actual graph
of this looks like